hidey ho reject nation you know
it has been a while it's been a while
since we reacted to
the corridor crew watch aaron lewis
himself
come and claim us cut to aaron lewis
this came out and i was like hell yeah
we gotta watch this
there's snyder cut a vfx artist react to
if i'm not mistaken there's a decent
amount of visual effects in snyder
cut a few of them yeah and i'm looking
forward to the comparisons between
snyder cut and joss whedon league yes
absolutely so weeds just league yeah
john
shall we begin
[Music]
we live in a society
oh yeah oh yeah
never really before in history have we
had the chance to compare
the same high budget films side by side
of itself
oh yeah it feels like it has more
momentum and weight the human lip
is the hardest thing to do in cg
man stephen wolf just looks like a dude
[Laughter]
hey what's up in black and white episode
of visual effects artist react today we
are looking at some incredible marvel
movies
scratch that no you heard that right
today we're looking at not just the
justice league
but the snyder cut and kind of comparing
the two because a lot of work was done
to make sure the snyder cut could happen
and i want to look at the differences
and a lot of money was spent too how
expensive was this movie because it's
like
they filmed the movie then they filmed
all the reshoots they did all the visual
effects for the original cut of the
movie and then for the reshoots
and then for the snyder cut each time
there's money being stuff billion
dollars
is probably the answer to that but no
one will know they'll keep that under
lock and key not even the mass detective
himself batman could think where is the
budget
right here everybody asked us to react
beautifully
that's super cool so hey we like those
comments keep them coming it helps us
know what to look at
in terms of just like the idea of doing
something like this cinematically
is crazy it is like unprecedented in
terms of film history because movie
studios don't go back
to revisit their stuff they'll like make
a sequel or whatever it's
the first time as far as we can tell
right where it's like okay cool everyone
wanted this original version fine we'll
go and do it again
yeah like normally when you see a
director's cut it's just it's using the
same source material
like with blade runner you know it's
like it's basically the same movie just
with a few different
implications what they didn't do is they
didn't go back and re-shoot blade runner
again
version of the original blade runner
never really because they didn't
reshoot a lot there exactly high budget
films side by side of itself
exactly which is why a close frame by
frame study of
the snyder cut versus the weaving cut is
a film school in the box because you can
infer everything from how does the
visual effects
approach differ from how does the script
writing and story level differ from
how long a shot's being held to what
sequences are rearranged and what else
they reshot
for the weeden cut versus the snyder cut
you learn quite a bit from it
it's important to have a good phylogeny
convention
it is barry allen
right away the color correction approach
is different look at the skin tone
difference period right like in terms of
the reds how much
more intensely colorful i know
saturation colors get them out of my
face
arguably color grading is visual effects
it's you taking your film and
manipulating the colors putting
vignettes on masking certain things out
you know swapping the blue hue of the
sky for more of a
gold or something like that like that's
visual effects people think of
color grading as just like dropping a
filter on top of footage
that kid's a real hollywood color like
no there's actually a lot of specific
attention played out in different parts
of an image just to
get those colors and lighting contrast
right for for everybody who kind of like
makes fun of like oh zach's center of
justice league is like oh it's all muted
and stuff
that's like well no he's still getting
tonality out of it
snyder's almost has like a metallic look
to it yeah
nice difference in the snare cut square
frame for free
versus widescreen so this is actually
something that i think is really
interesting it's a huge huge thing i
mean
it became a meme right oh the snyder's
vision here's the thing i think is
interesting about 4-3
i've always felt that super widescreen
for superhero movies makes the
superheroes look small like when there's
a big
vista and the person doesn't quite fit
in that frame it's like just from a
visual standpoint i've always felt like
it makes
human figures and wide vistas look tiny
which is not the
emotional feeling of superhuman
superheroes are that big larger than
life characters
so weirdly enough when i look at the
square format stuff comparing the two
movies when i watched it i actually
really liked
the square form because it made the
individual characters feel like these
like god like
figures more so than i think widescreen
does i'm pretty
that's what zack snyder was setting out
to do
yes it's the imax cameras but he's
talked about that how
that's like a comic book panel that's
crazy that he picked up on that
i arrived at it independently i was like
more over the pages
of what i imagined the reason for the
four bytes it's not like four by three
what what is it exactly
whatever the square is okay i thought
that was more about just representing
like the pages from a comic
i didn't ever associate it with the
depth and the size
of the heroes as he's pointing out here
when you're dealing with the dceu
which is more of the gods you kind of
want to have that
sense of giants amongst us it's an
excellent point i'm pretty sure the
original justice league movie was
finished at the wide screen the vfx
shots were finished at that aspect ratio
did they have to go back and re-render
them with the extra resolution up on top
and bottom
this movie is why it's important to have
a good file naming convention structure
for your project
because you never know when you need to
go back and open up those
old files you can't have you can't open
up that folder and be like oh
shot 30-1 version three final final four
oh which one is it you can't have that
and that's all on weta like they did
such a good job being able to like
bring up their old project files but
here's the thing it's one thing about
this
project files but you can't just like
make it really helpful for the new stuff
that they're adding here
we're gonna have to like dive into that
here oh intro this would be a damn good
one it's gonna be a good one
you can learn today
i love this thing i love it they've
adopted the
structure so i think it is time to
address
probably the biggest elephant in the
room
steppenwolf and i think it's very safe
to say
that one is quite a bit cooler than the
other
that's a mild way of putting it and
steppenwolf just looks like a dude in
the 2017 version no like he is
the original steppenwolf which is okay
to clarify
the steppenwolf we see in justice league
is not the original steppenwolf the one
we see in the snyder cut
is the original that was the original
design they they had
it this character in bbp before joshua
came on board
like it looked like that and they
redesigned him
i don't not intentionally to make him
look lame but that was the result
so one thing that is interesting to me
looking at the character design right
one of them i just don't buy
winning against a bunch of amazon
superheroes right like
the one that in this giant scaly metal
thing is like i buy
a bunch oh it was cool it didn't quite
work as well
if it's this guy in this costume with
the sort of medieval looking armor and
you have
eight different amazons holding him down
she doesn't quite have the same impact
i will say when i when i was watching it
i found myself like just
exploring the physicality of this cg
creature way more
just looking at his like chest and
looking at the little like the way his
shoulders are built like my eye had
something to do with like
during it you know seven wells armor is
super detailed right it's like hyper
detail there's little bits everywhere
now there's a big danger to doing
something like that because it can very
quickly become
noise and it would be a danger of you
losing any of his form if you did that
there's two things they did to to fix
that one
is his silhouette is super clean and
smooth the fact that the suit is so
shiny
you can still see the you know bright
white outlines of his of his body as he
moves there's not little spikes
everywhere that's one of the problems we
run into with the transformers robots
yes
actually yeah there's not really a
readable silhouette but
there's another thing that is
maybe this is a little smooth but it's
still just noise everywhere right
well that's what you could have had
happen with steppenwolf and that is what
happens with his helmet in the 2017
version
is that it's just a bunch of squiggles
which is basically the same thing as
just noise
in the new version there's a pattern
almost like the direction of your hair
to all the pieces of his armor and one
of the things the human eye is
surprisingly good at
is detecting parallel lines and then
changes in those lines
like i could put a big like pile of
noodles on the floor i could take and
they could have them all point the same
direction and i could take them on that
before by the way
and take one noodle and turn it from the
direction of all the others and you can
just look at it and immediately that
noodle's in the wrong spot
yeah and like it seems normal until you
think about like
your eye can process a thousand objects
and immediately tell instantly when one
is not aligned
and that's the thing that they're
relying upon with steppenwolf's armor is
that by doing the pattern and flow to it
you're also getting shaped like clear
distinct like macro shapes in his armor
even though it's made out of a bunch of
micro shapes
you know what's so cool about what they
just pointed out too the steppenwolf and
justice league is a lot
simpler yet everything they're pointing
out is it's more distracting though
everything about his design actually
becomes more noisy the original design
of steppenwolf the one that's in zack
snyder's justice league abundantly more
detailed and has
so much more going on with its armor
throughout the movie
yet nowhere near as distracting and more
lived-in but nowhere near as noisy which
i think is
kind of crazy that you can actually put
a whole lot more into the design and yet
it's less noisy yeah and speaking to the
point that i think nico's making
is like you notice part way through is
like the little plates are shifting and
stuff and it plays with that ability of
your eye to hone in and be like oh man
so many little details are moving around
the fine line yeah between something
that is
distracting and something that is
engrossing and some of the animations
with the new model
you can see in in some of the sequences
it's just it's a wavier animation set
they went in and read and
just tweaked it and like you can look at
some of the movements in earlier
versions and then
see where it ends up in the snyder cut
you can actually see it evolve from
being like
this feels floaty to like oh this feels
like a little more like there's
something there and there's momentum
behind it
there's like weight yes yes
there's one shot of steppenwolf that
literally made my jaw just drop when i
saw it when you pick them up just take a
picture i don't care to look at the
interaction between the liquid and cg
characters i thought was to pick them up
oh yeah oh yeah that's a 3d polo right
there oh
yeah just put a puddle in there make it
harder
oh wow yeah man for everybody
put puddle in there get the water oh but
it's more than just the puddle there's
mud yeah yeah
[Laughter]
people have no idea how much effort just
went into that one small moment oh
that's fantastic
merge and marry steppenwolf with the
scene it's small tricks like that that
really helps sell
cg objects as being real interaction but
i can see that mud in the water being
actual displacement from a real person
just watch it stick under his left foot
the way that stick moves a little splash
in the water there looks so
real yeah look at the size of his foot
no one's walking around with a size 48
feet big blue boots big old boots dog
come on move
to make a stick bounce in the perfectly
realistic way like that that's just
good artistic detail ah i think that
that stick feels real to me yeah it
feels real to me too
maybe wedda will let us know yeah no
here i actually would be
super interested to see a breakdown of
this specific shot
whata hbo whoever warner brothers make
it happen
i feel like they could have gotten zack
snyder he's actually on so many youtube
channels and i feel like zack snyder
would be a perfect candidate to be out
here weirdly it's like it's so easy to
chalk up all the effects and go yes that
will look like [ __ ] before
or this look bad before it looks so much
better now out of everything we've
talked to we've talked extensively about
the snyder cut at this point this is the
first time we're really deep diving into
the
differences and the details of the vfx
everything's been about is the story
and all that that much better than it is
absolutely i mean we did like a four and
a half hour spoiler talk on it
and it's all mainly character and story
beats and then here with the vfx you're
like well damn that was also
four hours of different visual effects
that we
just have kind of gotten used to or
taken advantage of or we just expect it
to look great because of zack snyder you
know and when you watch this
damn that is pretty crazy that not only
did we get a better told movie
and a better pace movie the vfx from
beginning to end or that much better too
yeah and i mean he's absolutely right
like even just watching these
side-by-sides up until now it's like i'm
learning so much about not only the
construction but you know the
considerations of how the effects do
enhance the story
[Music]
is that he is yeah look at the
amazonians
[Music]
props a snider for showing the stunt
people hit the ground when they do the
stunt
like in the original cut she hits the
wall and it cuts away it's like the wall
impact isn't what's
important it's the impact on the ground
that's important i mean anybody can go
huh it's the it's the it's the wreck
yeah yeah
snyder's someone who i think when you
look at his work is someone who's like
obsessed with the dynamics of the human
body and and stunt people in their
movement
i think it shows because the snyder
version feels like it has more momentum
and weight
more physics more palpable so she's
going to make a run for it
there's a real cost here needs to get
out with the box right
they're gonna have to break the wooden
supports in order to drop
gates trapping themselves into the home
knowingly doing something to me this is
a huge difference between the two these
shots here
of these amazons knocking down the oh
it just looks so ugly in 2017
that he gives you the entire wind up all
the way around
which gives you the sense of the weight
and the heaviness of it what do you get
in the weeden cut you get the last bit
of it of just the impact
it's not about the impact it's about
this herculean effort to like
throw this hammer all the way around
just like these are giant
larger than life beings destroying
things it's so much more intense
holding it up and how much of a buildup
it is
huh yeah man long
long slide shot all the way slow all the
way and you see this
finality of it closing as opposed to in
the again in justice league it's just
like cool okay they're just trapped in
it because there's no point
and then what's crazy here is that the
original justice league
they just leave and then he busts
through the wall and chases after them
but in the snyder cut you you're like
there are hundreds of people in that
thing and it's now
falling into the ocean they are all
dying right now he's just like
when i watched the snare coat of this i
was just like like my jaw was literally
dropped so
this thing was so much cooler and we're
not even talking about the visual
effects that's like right there
look at this she's like a stunning
reactor though this amazing
shot is arguably a flawless shot like
the physics are true
they're like in love with this movie
this was definitely a money shot on
their list of like
important shots big money shot the dust
getting in there water interaction
god that's true i honestly forgot about
some of
what happens in in the jostus version of
what was kept but that's one i remember
when we did a reaction to it i was in
love with that moment where
the sacrifice was made because it
greatly builds
up our villain she goes through this
struggle they're all
struggling just to get it away from the
pair of demons and step and wolf she has
to make the
ultimate sacrifice of her people and
they all go
descending into the depths of the water
and rubble did it make a difference did
it make a dent
steppenwolf and the spirit demons come
after no matter what she does and you're
like dan steppenwolf and the pair demons
are difficult to defeat it was
damn good story beat that is not felt at
all in the josh's version
no i mean it's induced it's it's reduced
to a set piece
yeah it's like oh here we go get some
action but you know yeah the
just that tooth and nails quality the
expanding on that footage is
it's funny like so much of the debate
has centered around like oh you know
like what is
truly different and what has just been
recontextualized or you know
expanded but those expansions can make
something feel
incredibly different from you know
something based on the same footage and
i think people can sometimes take
details for granted
whether it be like a little extra beat
or not you know yeah like them hitting
the floor
the glass melts that's amazing
some artists had to make a perfect movie
quality cg hot dog
i think i say overall this scene is
pretty dang great
like my my misgivings for like how it
actually happened with
her and momentum and all that stuff like
it doesn't matter he saves the woman
from a car crash
in a really cool slo-mo way how do you
think they filmed that though
i imagine she's on a wire it's kind of
like a wire
but i think it's actually a motion
control arm
she's got her hair pulled back so all of
the hair is
generated they did the cg hair also for
wonder woman when she's moving really
fast in that fight scene and she's
ramping all over the place and her hair
wouldn't move like that if you just did
regular speed ramps
but there's another aspect of her that's
computer generated that you might not
have realized
her clothes oh really because they need
a ripple in the correct way
yeah that's textbook oh you think you
know what cg what's cg in this shot
you're like
yeah what about all her hair in her coat
i could tell no you didn't
notice how he's being very careful to
keep his hands outstretched and not
actually
pressing down on her because they knew
that they're going to have to replace
all of that
so they didn't want to have like him
physically
conforming his hand to clothing that's
not there yet
they actually nailed the the surface
contact shadows between his hand
and her clothes really well
oh and they deleted all that
there are moments in the movie in the
snyder cut that they needed to do
basically reshoots without re-shooting
so what are they they took that from
madison
old footage they used old footage so
there's a scene between darkseid and
superman
and he's like all like sad and whatnot
but it's from man of steel
after zod dies that's like the actual
moment from the movie
years ago they added a little bit of a
cg tier going down his face too
the only thing jank is like that's your
cg
yeah i was like damn look at henry
cavill showing up
i mean it's a good cg too i've seen more
obvious looking cg tears
really wow actors just sometimes never
need to act
yeah not now now now that we got
glycerin we got cbg
i don't know in there oh damn that's
that's disturbing teardrop gate whoa
usually a tear was the mark of a good
actor
now it could just be seashell yeah man
next time we gotta have a full-on
crying based episode only crying scenes
very very
can't have seen harry potter does he cry
man of steel it's only because he wasn't
crying in the take there
it's not because he can't cry because
that's the mark of a good actor yes
crying it's the one metric the only
thing jank is the shadow from
darkseid as we talked about in the harry
potter piece it's really hard
to add shadow on something that's
already lit
but i mean that being said they did a
really good job here it doesn't take you
out of it at all
it's just a cool detail that it's like
you know in order to make something
happen you pull out all the stops to you
know just do what's necessary oh you got
to use old footage
well make it work
[Music]
can we ask you some questions
another thing that blew me away when i
went back to re-watch the justice league
was that the snyder cut opens on this
really like moody moment of superman
dying and yelling and sound waves going
out and then the original justice league
opens up with
this goodness for those of you who don't
know the story
henry cavill was currently working on
mission impossible five
six something like that mission bothell
mustache edition he was contractually
obligated to keep that mustache he
couldn't shave it for these reshoots and
they're like ah
you fix it in post right well the human
lift
is the hardest thing to do in cg truly
so in the new version
this is just not oh my god oh i really
see it now
this is a reshoot of henry cavill with a
mustache
in the snyder cut because those were
reshoots for the we think
yeah do you know what zack snyder he's
doing away with joss whedon's original
vision you know
i think we should bring it back we
should bring back the weed and cut
so i think we need to give superman the
mustache he deserves
yes yes do it yeah we have all of this
incredible
reference footage from mission
impossible of henry cavill with the
mustache what if we deep fake the
mustache
back onto all of the superman shots
because superman needs a mustache
that's right we are releasing the
mustache cut so subscribe for that video
it's coming out very soon
no peter here absolutely and he doesn't
do things
not at 900 percent i mean how big would
superman's mustache actually be good
question i mean you guys know how
superman shaves right
they address this there's a canon
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
weird thing to exist it takes so it's
right there's so many things that had to
come together for
this movie to exist it's one of these
weird artifacts of film history
that happens so rarely that when it does
it warrants your attention
and uh you know what if you're in the
film definitely recommend
going frame by frame and really thinking
about what the differences are and how
they affect the final product and your
perception of the final product
you know there's a lot of comments on in
these threads talking about how great
dungeons and daddies is
no people liking the podcast yeah so
people are listening so i've been doing
this podcast called dungeons and daddies
it's a d d podcast
this last year also been helping out my
dad with uh his book which
describes his uh escape from the chinese
cultural revolution by swimming the
channel
between wow five or six mile swim which
is free yeah that like five or six miles
did you train but if you're swimming
that how long did it take
it took him eight hours eight hours of
swimming
uh floatation device the whole thing he
wrote a book about it
don't spoil the book freedom you can
pre-order it right now it's on amazon
the shocking thing had his whole
whole video with his information about
his
if you like dad videos consider
subscribing we got them coming out
everything oh clint's still on the
bottom
nice these days oh even though he left
that's cool you content gluttons
the mustache cut don't forget subscribe
if you don't miss it it's gonna be a
good time
wait oh yeah man that just made me
appreciate this
undercut that much more just when you
thought you didn't appreciate it anymore
you're like my appreciation is maxed out
nope just when you thought your own
appreciation for justice league couldn't
get any greater either
like they left all this work on the
table
well i guess what i didn't notice
like in some of those shots especially
the one where he's with lois on the farm
when they had the side by side the lip
thing i had noticed but i didn't realize
the whole reshaping of kind of his
cheekbones and face death perhaps his
head
gets a whole puffy it's not just here
it's it's literally like
it's like stretched out yeah yeah
because i was thinking like i don't know
if they he would have been allowed to
shave around it because throughout
fallout he has like a five o'clock
shadow to support that mustache so it
feels like while the mustache gets all
the you know attention it seems like
they probably would have had to go in
and smooth that
entire bottom half of his face you know
his lower jaw and everything well that
was a great video
i really love that one it's very
informative um
miss these guys hey subscribe record
crew if you haven't done so already
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell last but not least
maria hammond maria my dear um i sent
you an
extensively long message the other day
and
i just want to say thank you for being
encouraging and being
understanding supportive and all the
kinds of mental and emotional ways i
need you've been an incredible rock
uh in in our lives my life specifically
i
am really grateful that you are someone
who
enjoys our company and our attention and
is not sick of us and is understanding
if we are lacking in something so thank
you my dear you're
you're an amazing spirit just want to
sincerely hop on here and say thank you
much love undercut it well hey
i don't really care though because uh
you sent me t-shirts and that's about
the extent of our relationship so thanks
for that maria send some more
that was mean i'm not good
[Music]
because think of how much greater the
release will be
ultimately when we find it when we when
we bumble our way toward that
relationship